let's bring in Jason Chaffetz former
chairman of the House Oversight and
Government Reform Committee a Fox News
contributor as well all right Jason so
it sounds as if when you look at the
number of people who have already tried
to get the loans through the this
program something like seventy billion
dollars has already been processed
250,000 small businesses so far clearly
there's a need and clearly perhaps they
underestimated how much money they would
need up front or is this just how
Washington works get a little now get a
little later
it's just how Washington works they got
the money out in a remarkable fast time
I talked to a company yesterday who
actually got funded I realized there are
a lot of others that are waiting but I
think Congress knew that two trillion
dollars is already a big number they
needed to start this but they knew that
there was going to have to be this
fourth package to come in behind it
hopefully they don't lard it up the
Congress is notorious for doing it but
hopefully they don't lard it up with a
bunch of other garbage but they probably
will yeah it's that and they got to also
find a way to get the money that's
already been earmarked to the right
people to small business and the
unemployment money that's given to all
the states the states aren't equipped to
give anyone unemployment so what are
people gonna do as they wait for the
twelve hundred as they wait for their
loans grants and they wait for their
unemployment checks meanwhile bill Barr
was on with Laura last night and talked
about where this whole thing started in
in China and the lack of accountability
in China and WH o au was siding with
China and not telling us the truth about
how bad things were bill Barr weighs in
the bigger threat to America's election
security Russia or China in my opinion
it's China and and not just to the
election process but I think across the
board there's simply no comparison China
is a very serious threat to the United
States geopolitically economically
militarily and a threat to the integrity
of our institutions given their ability
to influence things is this the time to
take them on or do we wait for the
pandemic to subside if in fact jason
Chaffetz you do agree with Bill Bars
assessment I think bill Barr is exactly
right obviously you worry about Russia
you worry about Iran you worry about
North Korea but long term and short term
China has the resources and they're
generally much smarter and much quieter
about how they go about corporate
espionage espionage on our government on
our military what they're doing in outer
space that a lot of Americans that don't
have any exposure to there's a reason
why the American president Donald Trump
put up a space force and the China is a
big part of the reason why to do that
but also the economic ties and when we
throw out 22 trillion dollars in debt
and then go to the Chinese and the
Japanese and the others in say hey by
our debt we create and exacerbate the
problem and so the Attorney General is
exactly right and anybody who's looked
at any intelligence in Washington DC is
certainly during the years that I was
there recognizes that China is the
biggest threat so the Trump campaign is
saying that the establishment Democratic
Party establishment won when Bernie
dropped out yesterday and leaving Biden
to get that presumptive nomination last
night Bernie was on The Late Show after
dropping out and this is what he had to
say I hope to be able to work with Joe
to move him in a more progressive
direction and I think Joe is a good
politician and he understands that in
order to defeat the president that
ordered the defeat Trump he's gonna have
to bring new people into his political
world and that he's gonna have to listen
to their needs young people working
people and maybe start moving in a
direction to some degree than he has in
the past Jason you think that'll happen
Oh birdie birdie birdie he didn't really
get out of the race he just sent a
Trojan horse in there to try to disrupt
the entire Democratic Party Bernie never
joined the Democratic Party he was the
major disrupter and now he's going to
cause all kinds of headaches for Joe
Biden if I'm the Biden camp
I am absolutely ticked at this guy
instead of wrapping my arm around Joe
Biden and saying hey let's get behind
and support him and defeat Donald Trump
he didn't do that he told his people to
keep on going keep fighting go to that
convention let's affect the platform
that works all to the advantage of
Donald Trump it's going to make Joe
Biden do things that are worse than he
wants to do and remember Joe Biden has
his own problem it's Joe Biden Joe Biden
was elected four years before Jimmy
Carter became the president of the
United States the guy has been locked in
Washington DC and now he's got this
Bernie Sanders problem and he's got a
Donald Trump who's doing an A+ job on
this coronavirus and an economy that I
do believe will come roaring back well
you know maybe we were talking to Chuck
Roker you know Chuck just about 50
minutes ago Jason and he said look this
has been such a crazy primary season you
never know what's gonna happen next so
you're right it throws a monkey wrench
into the Joe Biden campaign but
ultimately Bernie's looking for
influence and he wants his supporters to
feel like somebody's listening to him
otherwise they're not gonna show up for
Joe watch this I think he's encouraging
all of his supporters to actually show
up you want to make sure that our versus
our voice is heard at the convention
because we have a diverse party we won't
every every faction of the party to be
heard at the convention our coalition
couldn't win the general election Jill
Biden by himself in his coalition can't
win the win that November election
against Donald Trump together is the
only way that they have any shot at all
of winning and we may not get everything
that we want but there has to be some
kind of coming together of everybody to
make sure that we can defeat Donald
Trump
you know Jason Lee before the pandemic
really came to the United States it was
all about politics it seemed like that
was our lead story for so long for
months and months and months about the
campaign and the primary season but now
until this thing gets better and we
crossed the peak and we go way down the
curve are people really tuned in to this
know what Bernie Sanders did yesterday
is just acknowledge reality he can't
have his rallies he can't go out and
campaign the way he traditionally did
and so when he says he's leaving the
race he's not really getting out of it
because he's telling people to fight on
he's getting the Joe Biden supporters
out there to kind of lay down their arms
and say yeah you know what we're not
gonna fight anymore and meanwhile Bernie
Sanders is gonna kick people are gonna
continue to show up Jason let's be
honest it's gonna be Barack Obama
against Donald Trump Joe Biden's gonna
go out there say a few words hey did I
tell you I ran with President Obama and
he is going to be going the whole summer
that's what this is gonna be about and
that's what's going to be intriguing I'm
sure we're gonna hear more about that
shortly evidently he talked to Bernie
Sanders a couple of days ago which led
to this jason Chaffetz thanks so much
thank you